so yeah life's been okay you know we've
been having a good time um i gotta be
honest man uh i put up a story the other
day on my instagram about how my ocd was
just [ __ ] killing me
and i don't normally post stuff like
that
uh because you know i don't i don't know
if social media is supposed to be for
you know emoting so much but i know a
lot of people do it and they feel it and
and and it's good for them and and it's
their it's their brand and it's not
really mine
uh because i just kind of come on here
and [ __ ] and i do jokey stuff and i
talk about like [ __ ] hugh jackman but
like um
you know i i was really
i was taken aback by how many people
um
[Music]
were struggling with that as well um i i
basically um
i couldn't leave
the house i couldn't get out uh i was
just stuck in a loop and i don't know if
you know how serious uh you know i make
light of it a lot but like
i really have uh a [ __ ] pretty
hard case of ocd and sometimes
it's [ __ ] real tough um and i was
just stuck dude i was stuck in my house
and i couldn't leave i couldn't move um
and my anxiety was just [ __ ] killing
me it was getting the best of me and
uh it was anxiety and ocd and i was
[ __ ] i was just i
i think i had therapy earlier and i was
just really really really
just struggling and i finally got out of
the house um
at like three
which is so late for me man
and it was so [ __ ] hard um
and i was just [ __ ] up all day uh
and i just
i was just taken aback by how many
people reached out and said like i i
really appreciate you sharing this
because it's a struggle too it's nice to
know that like you suffer from this i
mean not not this nice to know that
anybody suffers from it but like that
like they're not alone i guess
um but yeah man
you know i think that sometimes
it's weird because the internet like
looks at people i don't mean to get so
[ __ ] i usually like to start with
some [ __ ] funny [ __ ] but like
it's weird to see that like some people
like on the internet especially like
celebrities you know you see them
getting dragged for all sorts of [ __ ]
and like just people think that their
lives are amazing like i look at like
guys like
the rock or
whoever um and i just wonder what their
life is really like
because
you know he's a person and i know it's
go go go but
all it takes is like a certain moment to
just realize oh [ __ ] man i've been
really going too hard or really been not
taking care of myself and my mental
and uh i think that that's important you
know sometimes you coast through therapy
or sometimes like i go to my meetings
and i like i i don't know i feel like
i'm on autopilot or something but like
i don't know it just hit me that i was
not like
taking care of myself
and i just had a [ __ ] rough few days
man um i went on stage and i kind of
tried to get through it i thought it
would get better and um you know it's up
and down but
um i just want people to know that like
i'm
i know that like economy for like humor
and [ __ ] and i said i wasn't feeling
funny today um i just really appreciate
you guys listening because like um and i
feel like you know since the response
from my
post which i don't normally share i mean
i even had like some like celebrities
reach out and they were like oh you know
yeah i suffer from the same thing and it
was just like wow
you know it was nice for me to know that
i'm not alone you know because i think
sometimes people look at people who have
2 million followers and they're like
that guy knows what the [ __ ] life's all
about it's just like
it's a constant [ __ ]
thing where you're trying to figure out
you're trying to grow and you're trying
to understand yourself and
how you're
managing your life and it's not perfect
and it's [ __ ] messy and um
so
you know um
yeah you're not alone dude i i my ocd
was [ __ ] killing me man like [ __ ] i
don't even like thinking about it but
it was a [ __ ] struggle
um
you get stuck in like a loop and i don't
even want to like
get out it's hard for me to even leave a
room because i leave a room and i get
terrified like
dude i leave a room and i get [ __ ]
terrified that i left the room the wrong
way or something or like i left
something in a wrong way and somebody's
gonna die or get cancer or some [ __ ] or
whatever the [ __ ] man something's gonna
happen to my family and it's [ __ ]
so
weird
[ __ ]
you ever see that [ __ ] movie with
hugh jackman with the robots
where he's just like [ __ ] what's that
robot [ __ ] thing were they punching
they're punching [ __ ] heads and [ __ ]
what is it called real real deal dude
real steel
[ __ ] was that
[Laughter]
[ __ ] hugh jackman gonna be making
that movie and i'm [ __ ] trapped in my
[ __ ] bedroom
he's gonna be making real steel while
i'm [ __ ] thinking about how my whole
family's getting cancer when i turn on
the goddamn shower [ __ ] off
you're just gonna make real steel huh
yeah what's it about robots all right
well let's make it is crystalline stuck
in a room all right and action
[ __ ] being ripped this [ __ ] just so
ripped on [ __ ] tea
all right
i've only eaten meat and [ __ ] lettuce
wraps
just get off the set of wolverine
let's make a movie with robots hold on i
need to check something is crystalline
trapped in a [ __ ] room because he
can't leave without thinking his
family's going to die in an airplane
air
and action
so don't think i'm gonna be all [ __ ]
walls down the whole time and not bring
up [ __ ] goddamn hugh jackman and some
of his [ __ ] ass movies
to [ __ ] even it out baby because we
gotta even it out dude the walls go down
you start with the waterworks well hugh
jackman's getting it immediately dude
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]